I fought a an alien made out of black
goo once oh no way what is going on
everybody welcome back to the cosmic
wonder I'm Warren Thompson and it looks
like Sony has went ahead and revealed
not one but two logos for Venom 3 both
of which on their own but also together
seemingly tell us who the villain of the
film is now we know chiel G4 is going to
be playing Orwell Taylor and that is not
who we are talking about in this video
when we mentioned the villain the title
cards seemingly reveal a symbiote
villain which of course makes sense the
Symbiote Riot was the villain of the
first film the Symbiote Carnage was the
villain of the second film so we
probably couldn't get a Venom 3 without
having at least one other symbiote in
the film and although venom has kind of
strayed away a little bit from what
happens in the comics like you know
Eddie Brock getting the Symbiote B for
Peter Parker and I guess Carnage was
kind of The Offspring of Venom and Venom
2 but the point is they are not not
exactly doing it by the comic book and
it looks like Venom 3 is kind of going
to follow that same fashion with the
offsprings of Symbiotes and don't worry
of course we're going to be talking
about the possibility of Spider-Man
appearing in this film but which
Spider-Man Could It Be I'm sure we all
remember the post-credit scene of Venom
Let There Be Carnage and the post-credit
scene of Spider-Man no way home taking
venom out of the Sony Spider-Man
universe putting him into the MCU and
then ripping him back out and putting
him back into the Sony Spider-Man
universe will Sony actually deliver on
that we'll break that down in this video
but what's really interesting about this
logo reveal or I should say logo reveals
is that Sony recently changed the logo
they revealed the first logo about 10
days ago at CES of 2024 as you can see
here this logo was very similar to the
previous Venom logos the Venom letters
were silver with a reddish outline and a
big red three in the background and no
Carnage isn't returning the red three is
not for Carnage coming again but like I
mentioned this does tell us a little bit
about the Symbiote villain and so does
the new logo that's right Sony actually
changed their logo this was shown 10
days ago at CES and today they released
a new logo this was captured by collider
and as you can see here it looks very
different very different than what they
showed at CES but also very different
than the other two movies logos this one
is all blue with a hint of red and like
I mentioned both of them kind of tell us
who the Symbiote villain is going to be
and Venom 2 Let There Be Carnage
actually gave us a pretty good setup for
the next villain as well and that would
be toxin now if you're aware of toxin's
origin in the comics then you already
know his big Spider-Man connection but
first let's back up just a bit in the
comics Carnage comes from Venom and then
toxin comes from Carnage Carnage is The
Offspring of Venom and toxin is The
Offspring of Carnage and here's the
thing toxin is red and blue and
sometimes he kind of resembles
Spider-Man a little bit this explains
the change in logo at first the Venom 3
Logo was red which checks out toxin is
red and now the new logo is blue and
toxin is also blue he's literally about
half and half but you can see why Sony
wanted to change the Venom 3 Logo from
red to blue because red really makes us
think of Carnage and we've already had
Carnage he's not coming back but we do
have toxin now now like I mentioned they
already set this up because in the
comics Patrick Mulligan is the host of
toxin and we already met Patrick
Mulligan in venom 2 Let There Be Carnage
and we see seemingly saw him get the
toxin symbiote in this scene right here
we can see Patrick Mulligan's eyes glow
blue as he says
[Music]
monsters
monsters so this is kind of different
than what happens in the comics but it's
also very similar because in the comics
in the origin for toxin we say Venom and
Carnage fighting Carnage makes it very
clear that he's about to become a father
and he's not very happy about and he
tells Venom that when it's born he's
going to kill it also if you are not
aware symbiotes reproduce asexually they
kind of just give birth they don't have
to mate with anybody to do it they are
aliens after all but basically Carnage
goes underground to give birth to the
new symbiote officer Patrick Mulligan is
on scene Carnage ends up putting the
Symbiote on him and fleas fearing that
Venom would come and defeat Carnage
because he was in a weakened state after
giving birth to toxin Mulligan has no
idea that he has the Symbiote inside of
him he goes home to his wife who is
pregnant and Venom showes up because he
tracked him down asking if he's going to
keep the child safe now Mulligan thinks
he's talking about his own child inside
of his pregnant wife but Venom is
talking about the Symbiote then
Spider-Man shows up trying to stop Venom
who he thinks is trying to kill them but
they ultimately figure out that's not
what's happening but then Carnage shows
up and he starts attacking everybody
Spider-Man Actually ends up saving
Mulligan's wife and takes her to the
hospital to go into labor Venom
explained to Spider-Man that he wants to
keep the Symbiote alive and he needs the
guidance of venom or else the Symbiote
might go crazy like Carnage however as
time goes by ultimately Mulligan
realizes that he has the Symbiote on him
and realizing that the Symbiote is
becoming more powerful than Venom and
Carnage with toxin easily defeating
Carnage oneon-one Venom and Carnage
actually team up together to try and
defeat toxin they show up to fight Toxin
and then Spider-Man shows up and fights
alongside toxin so we literally get a
Carnage and Venom team versus a toxin
and Spider-Man team and again toxin kind
of wipes the floor with them but this
could be an insanely cool setup for a
liveaction Spider-Man to appear in venom
3 we'll talk about how epic this could
be in just a sec but first big thank you
to Avatar braving the elements for
sponsoring this video I know many of you
love the breakdowns that we do Easter
egg videos reactions and reviews on this
channel which is why I think you will
love Avatar braving the elements the
official Companion podcast for avatar
The Last Airbender now I personally love
companion podcast that go with whatever
I'm watching at the time because I feel
like you just get so much more
information that you wouldn't get from
anywhere else which is why I am so
excited for Avatar braving the elements
each week hosts Janet vanney the voice
of Kora and Dante BOS the voice of Zuko
rewatch every episode of The Last
Airbender they're joined by special
guests like the casts super fans and
even the creators of the show Michael De
Martino and Brian kitko for a deep dive
and a behind the scenes look into the
Avatar verse that you can't get anywhere
else so listen to Avatar braving the
elements wherever you get your podcast
now everybody wants Spider-Man to appear
in venom 3 however like I stated before
the question is which Spider-Man Marvel
Studios made it pretty clear with Venom
1 that they didn't want Tom Holland
Spider-Man to appear in the Venom film
because they didn't want to confuse
people they didn't want people to think
that the universes were the same however
we are in the Multiverse Saga in the MCU
and the Multiverse is about to open up
in the spiderverse as well with a lot of
people believing that the two universes
really are connected and we could see
Tom Hardy's Venom showing up in Avengers
Secret Wars but I think the most likely
option for a Spider-Man appearing in
venom 3 is most likely Andrew Garfield
Spider-Man especially with that comment
in Spider-Man no way home where he said
that he wants to fight an alien I want
to fight an alien and after Spider-Man
no way home reports came out that said
Sony was not done with Andrew Garfield
and that he did want to return to play
spider man again especially after that
very huge Redemption Arc that he had in
Spider-Man no way home so the question
now is if a Spider-Man does show up what
role exactly is he going to play is he
going to fight against Venom helping
toxin this way we finally get our Venom
vers Spider-Man moment or are we going
to have to wait to the MCU to get that
because make no mistake there is going
to be a Venom in the MCU technically
there is the Venom symbiote in the MCU
right now when Venom went to the MCU and
left of of course as we saw he left a
part of the Symbiote behind this will
eventually bond with Peter Parker
unfortunately it doesn't seem like Eddie
Brock is going to be played by Tom Hardy
in the MCU But ultimately we will get a
Venom vers Spider-Man in the MCU the
only question is do we get a Venom vers
Spider-Man in venom 3 Tom Hardy said
that that was his goal that was his
final goal his endgame but did Sony
actually allow it to happen in venom 3
I'm hoping so but let me know your
thoughts about all of this news in the
comments down below about toxen about
the new logos and the possibility of
Spider-Man showing up in venom 3 leave
your comments down below please don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
to the channel and if you sub and leave
a comment you're automatically entered
in our giveaway for chance to one A PS5
and Xbox series X some Marvel Legends
items or some DC items the winner gets
to pick one item and we pick one winner
at the end of each month you can find us
on Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof